Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
So this is going to be a bonus Game of Thrones video
about what they might do after season 7.
They just made up a whole bunch of comments
about going beyond 10 years,
that doesn't necessarily mean that we'll
get Game of Thrones season 10.
So this will be a breakdown of the
storyline they can do as well as
what would George R. R. Martin had to say
about it.
So if you didn't see it, there was an
interview with the president of HBO
programming
the person who's responsible for
buying new shows.
He said, "We would love to go beyond 10
years with Game of Thrones
as of right now the actors are only
confirmed
through season 6. There's only a contract
with HBO through season 6.
There have been a lot
of HBO shows that a run for a long time
seven seems like the magic number. Even
for unsuccessful series.
So, I don't think that it's going to be a
problem getting to season seven.
There's just there's too much material
to wrap it up in six seasons.
They're already skipping so much stuff.
What's probably going to end up happening
is the producers Dan and Dave,
as well as the actors,
will not want to go beyond season 7.
So here's a breakdown of likely
outcomes in this situation where you
have like a whole bunch material
but a limited amount of time to
get it out. So, most likely
what's going to happen is we'll get
season 7 and they'll rap the series up,
you know, for the most part. And have to
cut out a whole bunch of stuff like
they'll cut out a lot of stuff!
Moving down the list a little bit,
season 8 - slightly less likely.
I would put it at like 60 percent chance
that they'll do season 8
to wrap things up. As for the odds a
movie, George R.R. Martin himself said
that you know, yes it'll be great to do a
movie but the president
of HBO said that he wasn't
really hot on the idea...
Just because HBO's driven by
television subscribers.
Even if the aired the movie on HBO,
you'd be paying
a full month's subscription fee for two
hours of programming
out of the four weeks of programming you
would normally get. So just as a
cost-benefit analysis, the
executives at HBO feel like there's
better value
in not doing a movie. That doesn't mean
they won't ever do theatrical stuff again
regardless of what happens with
the show,
they'll probably do IMAX screenings again.
I think they were really successful
financially. People really liked them. But
would probably happen is
they'll wait till after the episodes
air on TV to do that. They're not gonna
throw subscribers under the bus.
Subscribers are there first priority.
So sidestep -
What is the alternative?
Starting a spinoff!
That's probably what's gonna end up happening.
We'll get like 7 series the main show
and then they'll do a prequel series as a spinoff
so we will get like 10-15 years of
Game of Thrones or however many
the spin-off runs for.
But the other material beyond season 7
will not be part
of a Song of Ice and Fire.
It'll be like prequel stuff.
Right now that's what The Walking Dead is doing.
Most popular TV show in the world.
Walking Dead is like the only show that's
more popular than Game of Thrones.
Robert Kirkman and ANC want more
Walking Dead, but they make
a ton of money on it, so they want as
much as possible. But there's only so
much they can do with the main cast.
At a certain point they'll run out of
stories to tell. People will just get tired,
the actors will want to move on
and do other projects,
just like the Game of Thrones actors.
Or they'll become too expensive to pay.
Usually the big problem beyond season 7
is that you have to give the actors like
astronomical raises, especially on really
successful TV series.
When you do a spin off you completely
bypass that problem.
You can bring in total unknowns, you
already have brand awareness,
so it cost way less. It's way easier to
produce. And you already have the built-in
audience from the main show.
it's really an embarrassment to bridges
in terms of like a Song of Ice and Fire
prequel material for them to pick from.
But I feel like there are two really
likely candidates.
There's the Tales of Dunk and Egg
and then there's the Targaryen Civil War.
Of the 2 of those, I feel like the most likely candidate
is just the Tales of Dunk and Egg. Just
because Martin spent a lot more time
developing that story line
and he said that beyond the three novellas
that he's done
he will write new material, but right now
he's working on Winds of Winter
as everyone is yelling at him. So it's
probably going to be a long time before
there's new Dunk and Egg stuff.
The really funny thing about
canonical material
outside of the Song of Ice and Fire is that
like every time George R. R. Martin does the
new public appearance, he talks about doing
'other' storylines that don't have to do
with the main novels.
It's so funny! So he's always announcing
new material. He'll be writing
new stories until he's dead in the
grave. It'll be a talking situation where
his heirs will have to finish his material
based on notes that he's left. There's just
way too much stuff for him to finish in
his lifetime!
I know some of you are asking,
"Why don't they do a series about Ancient Valeria?"
"Why don't they do a series about
Aegon's Conquest?" I think the answer is
that some stuff just works better in
flashback - when you just get like brief
looks at it.
Those are two really good examples of
storylines
that will require heavy digital effects.
Because you have lots of dragons,
lots of really big battles,
AND lots of big ecological destruction.
All of Doom of Valeria. Even if you don't
do the Doom of Valeria,
there were so many dragons you couldn't
throw a stone without hitting a dragon
in Ancient Valeria! Think about
how much they would have
to spend on digital effects.
So, Dunk and Egg, just a better choice. Just
WAY WAY less special effects required.
Much easier to produce. Some of you guys
are probably asking, "What the hell is Dunk and Egg?"
You probably heard the names before, you
probably heard them referred to...
but you may not have read the short
stories or the novellas. So
'Dunk' refers to Ser Duncan the Tall
that's this guy right here.
And 'Egg' refers to Aegon Targaryen the Fifth.
The individual novels that their stories
are in are out of print right now but
this fall in October, George R. R. Martin is
collecting
a new edition with some new artwork
- just like he did
with The World of Ice and Fire last year.
The difference is, is that The Tales of Dunk
And Egg is
all George R. R. Martin's writings. The World of Ice and Fire - I know a lot of people were
upset because it was just a
collaboration.
he only wrote part of it. It was still
fun book, but for those that
just wanna read stuff that George R. R.
Martin has wrote, Tales of Dunk And Egg
is much better. Their adventures mostly
covered this period of time before
Aegon had become the king and Ser
Duncan had become part of his Kingsguard.
Here's a quick breakdown on how that
storyline gets started.
So just careful for spoilers if you don't
want to know anything about Dunk and Egg.
The series picks up when Duncan is only
a squire...
hoping to become a knight. The knight that
he is serving under is nicknamed
The Hedge Knight. He dies while he and
Dunk are on their way
to a tournament in Ashford.
Duncan seizes the opportunity
to become a knight much faster.
Normally it takes a long time
to become a knight.
So he takes the Hedge Knight's armor and
gives himself the name
Ser Duncan the Tall, saying that the
Hedge Knight knighted him right before he died.
The problem when he
gets to the tournament in Ashford is
that no one believes him.
Nobody remembers the Hedge Knight
except for
one of the Targaryen princes.
Prince Baylor. He agrees to let Ser
Duncan fight in the tournament.
So he's bluffing his way
into the tournament,
and he's kinda on shaky ground.
He stays in an Inn. And it just so
happens that
a young Targaryen Prince named Egg,
nicknamed Egg, is staying there.
So Egg or Aegon the Fifth
(however you want to think about him)
is like so far down the line of succession
that he doesn't even care about becoming
king. He wants to become a knight so that
he can become a Kingsguard some day.
Most of his family think this is
blasphemous. And he has several siblings.
He has an older brother that's kinda like
Joffrey. Total dickhead! Way further up
the line succession than him.
Even his father Prince Maekar the First
is still a prince!
You have to remember that like at this
time in history
they're just lousy with Targaryens
there's Targaryens everywhere. Like each one
of them has like a billion kids!
Because Egg is staying at the same Inn as
Ser Duncan he seizes the opportunity to
try and become
Ser Duncan's squire. He begs him. He's like,
"Please let me be your squire!"
But he doesn't tell him that he's a
Targaryen prince. He just lies about his
identity - he says his name's Egg.
Duncan agrees, but then later in this
kinda misguided active chivalry, Duncan
ends up in a trial by combat
with Egg's older brother Aerion Targaryen.
Here's where things get really cool!
So Aerion challenges Dunk to a trial by
combat but not just any trial by combat
not like Oberyn Martell verses the
Mountain.
He challenges him to a trial by seven. Trial
by seven
is seven on seven trial by
combat where seven knights
face seven other knights all seated on
horseback.
You can pick whatever
weapon you want to use.
Usually it's lances though because you're on horseback.
Dunk is able to win, but in a series of
unfortunate events
a whole bunch really important people
died, including Baelor Targaryen.
Egg's uncle. Egg's father, Prince Maekar
says that because he won, he
could become part of his personal guard.
Dunk refuses and says, "I just wanna be a
knight" and Egg's father agrees to let
Duncan squire Egg who at this time had
revealed himself as Aegon the Fifth.
But he still way down in the line of
succession, so he thinks he has zero
chance at becoming king.
The rest these three stories just go on
to tell their adventures
after that. You know, to deal with a couple
of really big important events in Westeros.
So, there's a lot of
really big stuff happening outside of
what's going on with Dunk and Egg.
So it's pretty exciting - it's a really good story.
There's just enough battles for
them to do
some really cool action set pieces.
It's like a Song of Ice and Fire if it were
told from the perspective
of Brienne or Jaime Lannister.
So you get a much deeper dive into the line
of succession inside the Targaryens,
as well as what knighthood is like. It's just
a lot of fun.
I know I said that it's a little less likely
that they might do Dance of the Dragons
or you know, the Targaryen's Civil War.
The reason that
that would be really cool to do
is because they give a much
deeper dive into Dragon Lore.
Like, "What is involved in riding dragons?
How does that work?"
That series of short stories really explores that.
So it's way more dragon heavy. And it's
within about two hundred years
of the main series so it's not super
far removed, as opposed to like
Ancient Valeria. Here's my big question
for you guys: if they do
a prequel series, what would you rather
them do?
Would you rather than do Dunk and Egg?
Or would you rather than do Targaryen
Civil War or do you want to see something else?
As of right now, George R. R. Martin
has an option
to do a prequel series. As far as I know,
there hasn't been any
development along those lines.
But he said like after the second
episode, they started discussing
prequel series. Like literally after the
second episode George R. R. Martin had a lunch
with one of the top people of HBO and he was like,
"We want ten years of Game of Thrones!"
and George R. R. Martin was like
"That sounds great! I would love that!"
So most likely scenario
seven seasons in the main show and then
a prequel series would start, you know
around you know the time season six or
season seven starts. If they were going
to start a spinoff series
and they wanted to get it out by sorta like season 6,
or sometime you know, around 2016, they
really have to get going fast so
I think it's more likely that it would
start around season 7.
If they were actively developing spin
off right now which I don't think that they are
they would have already would have
announced some stuff. As of right now
they're just worrying about the main show.
My next bonus video is probably going to be like
a Daenerys like a straight up
Daenerys video for season five so be sure to
subscribe to get.
I may get that up by Sunday
at least by next week. If you guys really
want, I'll do a deeper video
on Dunk and Egg. There's just like there's SO much
material though it's really interesting!
Speaking of which, congrats to this week's
giveaway winner!
You win a copy of the season four DVD. Be
sure to message me on the backend of my
channel so I can get your contact info.
For those that are asking about the
HBO streaming service
HBO NOW. We have some more information
about that. What's going to happen is
it's exclusive to Apple. Meaning that you
have to have a
US App Store account or iTunes account
but it's actually the same thing. That
doesn't mean you have to live in the US
to use it it just means you need to be
able to buy things through the
United States Apple Store on a mobile device.
People in international
countries
there are a couple workarounds to do
this so, you can still use HBO NOW
but you have to buy the HBO NOW service
through the App Store.
And it has to be the US App Store I know
that sounds a little bit weird but
like SKY and other international
broadcasters
had exclusive digital rights to Game of
Thrones
in countries. So like, if you don't have HBO
NOW in your country,
it's because you're broadcaster doesn't
want you to have it, not because
HBO doesn't want you to have it so don't
yell at HBO!
Personally if you are in a foreign
country and you really want HBO NOW
I does recommend you try to work around.
Starting at the beginning of April I'm
still going to be giving away
subscriptions
if you are an international country
it'll probably just be PayPal, so you can
you try and find a workaround if you
want. So you can still win giveaways in
an international country so don't worry
about that.
So while you guys wait for that Daenerys
video, you can click here
for my break down in the second trailer -
way cooler than the first trailer!
And you can click here for my breakdown
of my synopsis of the first three episodes.
Thank you so much for watching! I'll see you
guys tonight. Now lets all do the thing!